ah look at all these
dudes i knew i smelled sausage
yes abby i'm liz liz
thank you oh our nips just touched mine
are so
hard mine are different sizes
abby these are the writers oh where's
little abby gonna sit
i guess i'll have to sit on somebody's
lap
you could sit there eenie
[Music]
[Laughter]
give me strength oh oprah
[Music]
i mean is that the new woman you hired
is it cold in here
or is it just that i'm not wearing any
underwear
you should be careful around the crew
new york gives us a tax break for
employing sex offenders
it's a terrible program
abby thanks for meeting me here this
place is very special to me is this
where you got your v card punched what
no does this look like the makeup room
of a clown academy
this is a statue and i know you know
this of eleanor roosevelt first lady to
the world
champion of the rights of women and the
lid on my high school lunch box
look i know it can be hard society puts
a lot of pressure on us to act a certain
way
but tgs is a safe place so you can drop
the
sexy baby act and lose the pigtails and
i like my pigtails
my uncle says they're sexy enough with
the gross jokes and that voice
i want you to talk in your real voice
this is my real voice
and the whole sexy baby thing isn't an
act i'm a very
sexy baby i can't help it if men are
attracted to me
like that homeless guy he likes what he
sees
okay that could be for me it's not it's
for her
abby i'm trying to help you really by
judging me on my appearance and the way
i talk
and what's the difference between me
using my sexuality and you using those
glasses to look smart
i am smart i placed out a freshman
german or lutz using that
sexy english accent to get me in the
sack no you didn't
what is that even possible i mean i was
there when he belvedered
god abby you can't be that desperate for
male attention you know what liz i don't
have to explain myself to you
my life is none of your business except
it is because you represent my show and
you represent my gender in this business
and you embarrass me
kiss dude i am sorry but this is who i
am
deal with it now are we gonna give the
gentleman what he asked for or not
ugh you know what sucked about my last
lesbian orgy
right in the middle of it one of us had
to get up to go use the bathroom
and then we all have to go okay
there's something everyone here needs to
see abby you might want to sit down for
this
yeah come sit on my strike of us on a
chair come on sue
abby this is for your own good open
apple tough love time
has anyone ever actually had a good time
at brunch
you know is that you i don't know where
you found that
but i am taking it down
that's what she said okay first of all
steve carell
owns that's what she said he owns it and
second of all
it's time to stop hiding a young person
helped me online post this
on joanofsnark.com you stupid
meddling yes there's your real
voice there's abby grossman
to quote eleanor roosevelt we are do you
understand what you've done
you have signed my death warrant how's
that now my ex-husband is gonna see this
he's gonna find out where i am and he's
gonna try to run me over with his car
again
i changed my appearance to get away from
him
oh cause i thought it was like pressure
from society you're right liz i was
hiding from a man who went insane after
being electrocuted while watching
sleeping with the enemy
i was cut out of that and yeah i am
desperate for male attention
because i feel safer having men around
in case troy comes back
that is why i slept with lutz and i
shall protect her is there an abby flynn
here
that's her troy i'm on your side get her
geez lust it's the ups
guy okay i think we all owe abby an
apology oh my god it's from him
i thought this box would be the perfect
size for your head p.s
i was electrocuted again while watching
seven
great i have six hours to start a new
life
i'll have to be a redhead this time oh i
don't know with your coloring
you know what don't listen to me you
must really hate women liz
liz lemon is a judas to all
womankind
you